el bloque inicial que se muestra abajo
tiene dieciséis novenos unidades de
longitud usa las herramientas a la
derecha para convertir el bloque inicial
en el bloque objetivo este es el bloque
inicial
este es el bloque objetivo y usaremos
estas herramientas convertiremos el
bloque inicial en el bloque objetivo que
tiene una unidad esto equivale a una
unidad tu progreso se verá reflejado en
el cambio de longitud del bloque de
pruebas si nosotros tenemos 16 novenos
aquí si corta este pedazo en 2
ahora tendré ocho novenos
estamos claros si lo corto en cuatro
tendré entonces cuatro novenos vámonos
hasta que tengamos un solo noveno
para que podamos llegar
las unidades totales para esto tendrá
entonces 16 novenos tendré 16
piezas de este tamaño si yo busco tener
una unidad y esto es un noveno entonces
tendré nueve novenos porque nueve
novenos serán una unidad
así es que copiaremos este noveno 999
veces tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho nueve y listo tenemos
exactamente una unidad que nuestro
bloque objetivo vamos a comprobar
respuesta y es correcta vamos a hacer
otra más
el bloque inicial que se muestra bajo
tiene cuatro octavos de unidades de
longitud usa los herramientas a la
derecha para convertir este bloque
inicial en el bloque objetivo nuestro
bloque objetivo ahora tiene tres octavos
nuestro progreso se verá reflejado en el
cambio de longitud del bloque de prueba
vamos primero a hacer un octavo
cortaremos esto entonces en cuatro
piezas para tener los octavos uno dos
tres cuatro con eso tenemos un octavo
esto es un octavo
y aquí teníamos 4 ahora nuestro bloque
objetivo busca tener 3
copiaremos un par de veces más esto
tenemos un octavo dos octavos tres
octavos y otra vez tenemos exactamente
la misma distancia comprobemos respuesta
es correcta uno más porque estos son muy
divertidos y vamos a practicarlo
el bloque inicial que se muestra tiene 9
séptimos este bloque tiene 9 séptimos
usaremos las herramientas una vez más
para que lleguemos al bloque objetivo
que son dos séptimos si estos son nueve
séptimos vamos a dividir nuestro bloque
inicial nueve veces para tener un
séptimo
ok esto es un séptimo
si nosotros buscamos llegar al bloque
objetivo de dos séptimos pues sólo nos
falta un séptimo más así es que lo
copiaremos una vez más y con eso tenemos
la misma distancia dos séptimos de
acuerdo a nuestro bloque objetivo
comprobemos respuesta y es correcta